flight b a double o a touched down at
london heathrow
laden with olympians and medals
these pictures were taken on board as
the last team gb
athletes and coaches made their way home
from tokyo
among them britain's golden couple jason
and laura kenny
just the 12 gold medals between them now
spread across
four separate games and what a
homecoming it was at terminal five
[Music]
the loudest chair greeted boxer galileo
phi
the former land rover factory worker is
now the first fighter from birmingham
with an olympic gold medal they
supported me when i went at the top now
i'm at the top now i'm olympic champion
they support me when i was at the bottom
so
i'll always be dead to them and i'd be
very thankful to all of them
teammate lauren price couldn't wait to
get home to wales
to celebrate her boxing gold reading
the messages i've received and the
support has just just edged me on a
little bit and it's been fantastic
and i'm just glad i'm bringing our medal
back to britain
and then there were the modern pent
athletes joe chung
and kate french who both took gold all
the hard work
it's paid off oh absolutely it's um it
literally is a dream come true i don't
know like
what else could top this right now yeah
it's just unbelievable
oh i'm quite emotional right now um yeah
so nice to see everyone after yeah very
exciting chef away
and what you've achieved has it sunk in
no no not yet to be honest yeah i feel
like i'm still in a dream
these were unprecedented games and team
gb's attention to detail
ensured not one single person out of the
thousand who traveled
tested positive for culvert if you look
back three or four months it felt like
we were in a trench fight to get
athletes vaccinated to get them out
there safely
in fact to deliver those athletes safe
and sound to the start line
of course once the sport took over the
athletes the athletes just excelled
so the athletes head home now to
celebrate
only two aware that paris is less than
three years away
and the brady sky news at heathrow
terminal 5.